how have president reagan's policies
affected the government since he left
office what ronald reagan did was set up
a titanic debate really between those
who believed in the new deal view of
government which was that it was there
to help those who could not help
themselves
and and manage
an enormous
economy and the enormous life of the
world's uh only superpower or at least
one of the two superpowers and what that
on the new deal side that was what
government should do on the reagan side
he said get government out of the way
and let american free enterprise and
individual initiative uh create
greatness in america again and so that
was just setting up that ideological
conversation now continued all the way
through newt gingrich's revolution in
1994 and his clashes with bill clinton
they were over the same kinds of things
that ronald reagan had brought into the
debate uh when he was elected in 1980
now the the challenge was that reagan's
defense spending and his tax cuts
ballooned the deficit uh and what that
ended up what ended up happening is that
the thing he had come to washington to
try to solve which was the budget
deficit
had actually gotten bigger and so reagan
who came to town as a tax cutter ended
up ultimately having to raise taxes to
solve some of those problems of having a
large deficit and why is that bad
because deficits lead to inflation and
inflation is what was strangling america
when reagan came into office inflation
was very high and unemployment was high
and so his solution to it while it
kicked off a strong economic recovery
also ballooned the deficit which is a
problem that is
still one they wrestle with today